it
take about 30 seconds
all right
all right
and
good evening good morning depending on
where you are my name is stuart creek
i'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn
and i'd like to welcome you to our
career master class
uh the secrets of successfully
navigating potential career pitfalls
our guest speaker today is lieutenant
colonel prem vass
he's the ceo of prehonje ventures and a
noted career coach
and before i introduce prem
i'd like to remind everyone
webex controls
to
put in
questions for prem to answer the q a
please put those in the q a function
those will go
into a list that we will ask
towards the end of the session
you can put in chat mental messages to
the panelists if you wish um
but do try to put your questions into
the q a
and we'll also be doing polls of
you the audience
and i'm going to start with this one
just as a test
and
this whole question we've been asking
people since the beginning of the
pandemic
if you're watching on live stream you
can put an answer into the
chat window or the
comments
but um this is a pretty simple question
how are you feeling today
um we've been asking this
through the pandemic to get a gauge of
how people are holding up with
wildly changing
directives and regulations and
outbreaks and lockdowns
so
about 10 more seconds
and
it's good to see that
two-thirds of you are doing well and
about a fifth of you are doing okay and
for the the folks who are not doing so
well we hope that this webinar will
give you uh some useful tools to
brighten your outlook for your career in
2022 so
let me
introduce prem
lieutenant colonel prem voss uh he's the
ceo and co-founder of prim honje
ventures
he is a business and life coach yeah
with credentials from
the ice iscp in singapore and more than
three decades of professional career
both in the
indian armed forces and in corporate
and welcome prim i'm going to
turn over the presentation to you
thank you thank you so much stuart hi
everyone so the picture that you see is
without my beard so i have grown this
beard during the pandemic so
that's slight change so let me now
go to the event proper i will
share the screen just a minute
here we go
okay
if somebody could confirm uh if you're
able to see my screen
it'd be great
wonderful okay so the topic that we are
going to deal with today is secrets of
successfully navigating potential
carrier pitfalls
now
stuart and i when we discussed this
earlier we chose this topic because we
we felt that this is something that a
lot of us had to go through during the
pandemic
and therefore you know let's see how we
can handle this
gary pitfalls has always been there but
how to handle this is something that
some of us figured out on our own and a
lot of us were trying to do our best
so i have decided to get all of that put
together with my three decades of
experience that i've got and plus i did
a survey so that i get the feel of the
ground i get the pulse and therefore uh
we will share all of that in this
presentation right
okay so let's go with the audience poll
the first poll that i want to check is
which country are you attending from
this session
and this
and the second one is
your work experience less than two years
three to five five to ten and more than
ten years
and we'll close the hole in about three
seconds
and here's the poll results for you
should be seeing the
experience poll
i'll see if i can get the
information for the
country okay so here we have an
experience which talks of uh
predominantly uh more than 10 years as
the 30th percent
and yes so you would definitely have an
experience of uh
the pitfalls let's check that out
the next poll would probably ask that
question and less than two years we have
thirty percent
that's wonderful okay
yeah and for the three to five years and
five to ten years yes you will have a
lot of lessons to pick up in this
session and i hope
it will be definitely of use to you
right can we go to the next one
yes
yes one second
yeah so we go to the next poll which
talks of
the number of carrier pitfalls if you
have experience till date none one two
to three or more than three
by the way uh the response to country
about 50 percent of our
audience today is from india
oh okay great
and we have countries from
all over the globe represented from
north america through
uh
asia africa
oh great in europe
until here nahim asks what is a career
pitfall
hold on for just a second
oh that's very interesting so
uh we have maximum who says they've not
faced it damn good i i hope you you stay
lucky this way and uh yes one we have
roughly about 21 percent and between two
to three carrier pitfalls is about 31
percent
and that's where it's the highest and uh
more than three we have about 14 percent
so it's kind of spread all across fine
perfectly so let's go to the next one
which just one second let me just go to
the next poll
the next poll talks about what according
to you
are the most
common reasons for carrier pitfalls
right a b c d e and f
expectation mismatch
you did not upskill not putting your
best effort a difficult boss life
compulsions
and lot of lack of better prospects
about 10 seconds left yeah this is this
is something which i would be very
interesting
result of this
here's the results
there
that goes as what i thought 52 percent
did not upskill myself yes
and uh then the next one comes to 39
which is expectation mismatched between
uh yes
what has been offered and what has been
the reality
and then we have the next highest one is
lack of better prospects which is
closely followed by a difficult boss
right and uh external life issues yes
those are those ones
fantastic okay so this is in lines of
what we had predicted and
we will take on this uh
presentation forward and it's more or
less stitched to what you have expressed
in these polls okay and that's great
so let me just go to the next one
okay so now what to expect from the
session
so when we talked about pitfalls so
pitfalls is something you know like
dictionary words if you're going by that
it is something
an unsuspecting danger or something
which is unexpected so that is what is
pitfall and you stitch that to the
carrier so we are talking about carrier
pitfalls
now there are two aspects to this
carrier pitfall so one is the
predictability
the other one is of course i mean it
just came out of the blue right but more
often than not
it is the predictability which applies
to the pitfalls
so i thought i must just make that clear
as to what is that we are looking at
when we are talking about as pitfalls so
the predictability if we have chosen not
to ignore the warning signs then of
course we really don't know
how it and why it hit us right but more
than
more often than not you will find that
there is a writing on the wall somewhere
so what do we expect from the session
firstly i will talk about the survey
that i did because i want to know what
across the globe what people think about
this particular topic so i will share
that
and then we will talk about top 10
career expectations
because everything starts with the
expectation if your expectations
are there
you have to
see how close it is to the reality
that's one of the reasons that leads to
a carrier pitfall so we will check out
what are the most top most carrier
expectations i got a whole lot of them i
just picked up the top 10
and then the reasons for the carrier
pitfalls
right we will take a look at that and
the top carrier pivots that goes to
happen thereafter so pivots is something
which we take a conscious decision to
shift maybe more than 180 or 270 or 360
degrees sometimes we will need to do
that so that pivot what is it we will
take a look at some of them and this
came from you
those who have done the
uh the surveys from the linkedin as well
as my whatsapp and my social media when
i shared the
survey
and then handling carrier pitfalls
this is what we are not going to talk
about the essence of what we have picked
up from all the three or four topics
that we are going to expect from the
session and then the tools and the
techniques that we can use to deal with
the carrier pitfalls
and finally a 10 carrier best practices
this is from the experience plus some of
you watched speaking to spoken to people
and we will list them out they could be
more than this but these could be if you
try them out perhaps you would not
need to you know come into a carrier
pitfall
and then how can i be of help i'm a
coach so therefore i do help people to
come out of the carrier pitfalls and how
do i do that i will explain in that and
then we wind up with the quest and
answer section
right now let's talk about this survey
that i did
most of you have said that carrier
carrier pitfalls are inevitable and
quite rightly so because there is a huge
amount of unpredictability there and and
we've seen this live in the past one and
a half two years when the pandemic hit
across planet earth
and we realized that there the pitfalls
are therefore inevitable and if it is
inevitable what are we expected to do
about it that's what we are going to
discuss in this session
right so when we did the survey you
would like to know who are the people
who participated so roughly 22
professions have participated so it's a
wide
wide base that we've got
the hr hr its itn ides
and the armed forces the veterans
they're the maximum who had
uh
you know done the survey
and and the rest of it is there these
are all more than five or ten people who
have
uh attempted the survey so i've put
those professions out here there are 22
of them so we have a fairly wide
coverage of people who would be facing
the
carrier pitfalls
right
so from that
and from the experience that i have
spoken to people
met so many of them
we
i have listed out 10 top carry
expectations the first one invariably is
reasonable work-life balance and
everybody
will agree to this and this is what we
are all looking for
and the second one in top in terms of
priority was aligning your career to
your passion and interest
interestingly there was an article today
in
in linkedin which talks about that it's
not passion that makes you happy when
you look for a job
and you must go read that and they say
that passion is okay but how most of the
people
people there said that
you learn how to love your job and that
is how
keeps you going and passion is something
which need not to be connected to your
job a very interesting reading i'm not
saying that we need to agree to that but
it's good to read that
then we have compensation which is
equivalent to the industry best
that is the expectation that we have
and
then the
compensation which is above average the
expectation is more than average we want
better than the others so that's a human
requirement so that is the fourth one
priority of carry expectations
and the fifth one is very clear carrier
progression
if you have a clear carrier progression
you are
you you feel that you know where you're
going and that is one of the important
expectations which came from many
and then comes the carrier stability
till you retire
so there is we're not talking about what
is the retirement because everyone has
their own
idea of retirement and plus the work
compulsions also gives you what should
be the retirement so it's in terms of
somebody wants to work to 30 somebody
wants to work till 40 45 60 or somebody
you know as long as the steam is on they
would like to keep working on so so that
is an end part of it but at least till
the time that they retire
they would like career stability and
that is one of the expectations
location preference
this is predominantly with the
ones who have started their families so
they have a commitment they want to be
near the best schools a city which is
provides good education for the kids
and those kind of things the younger
ones the freshers and people up to five
to not those who are not married or
staying single they're okay with any uh
location
a good boss to work with
surprisingly
uh this i was expecting to be one of the
top reasons is the carrier expectations
because
uh in uh 2019
um
there was a survey which was done by
the ddi and that was a consultancy firm
and they said that 50 percent
employees
leave
because of bad boss they can't handle
the boss 50 percent 57 percent sorry
and of this 57 percent 43 percent have
left the con their company at least once
because of a bad voice bad boss
and 14 percent have left multiple times
because of bad boss
right
so
that makes it 57 but what is even more
interesting is
32 percent of
them felt
that they should leave because of a bad
boss but they didn't do that they didn't
resign right so this was
that's close to 69 70 percent of people
using this as a reason uh to avoid a
carrier pitfall
right so
that is uh something interesting that i
thought i must share
and then a hybrid workplace this
obviously thanks to the pandemic
um
[Music]
association of chambers of commerce
accoc
cham they have mentioned in a study uh
this took place in october 2021
and in that they said that
by 2024 17
of increase will be the
uh the gig workers
and the gig workers predominantly are uh
are working on their own and in this uh
hybrid workplace because of what they
have observed still now they say
that
26 hours per month is the increased
productivity during this hybrid
workplace
and for the employer too it's very good
because that much of increased
productivity now this is just an overall
statistic
it may vary from companies to company
another important thing which they also
said was that
this
the hybrid workplace is something which
has benefited the employer more than the
employee because of cutting down of the
overheads okay
so that is something which is very
interesting and then the gig
opportunities this is something which
phenomenally went up 17 percent in by
2024 you can expect that's what the
study says 17 of them and that totals up
to
us dollars
455 billion that is the kind of money
that's going into the gig opportunities
and a lot of people have upskilled
themselves during this pandemic and have
chosen gig opportunity and it's going to
pick up and that's where it's going to
so hybrid and gig right now it's 10 with
the expectations
let's say if you do the same session
maybe after two years from now this
would go up in the carrier expectations
now let's take a look at what were the
carrier pitfalls the reasons for this
and the top 10 reasons are
they did not upscale and we have seen
that you know the in the poll that we
did too the upskill was what these
highest
percentage that we had 58 percent i
think or 38 yes
not putting the best effort
you
know that you can do the best but you
just
okay i just work for the pay that i got
that's it and that was the attitude and
when it came to laying off people these
were the ones who got hit
okay
and then
the third reason and the top most reason
was underestimating your potential to
upskill you know you had a potential but
you just did you took things for granted
so that was one the one of the third top
reason for the carrier pitfall
and life completions this is more or
less
not controllable one in the sense that
they had no choice but to use life
compulsions because of health because of
the pandemic how it badly affected us
the finances and of course uh the job
opportunities
and this and the family of course all of
this is forming the life compulsions
that we're talking of
and yeah this is staying in comfort zone
all of us like the comfort zone but the
guys who moved out of the comfort zone
where the ones that stayed on were more
stable
so this is something similar to the 0.2
which is just not putting the best
effort
and then you got stuck in your carrier
quicksand let's say you are a teacher
for instance and
and you you don't want to change or you
didn't want to change because you just
did your graduation you specialized in
teaching and you didn't want to change
although you may have a requirement or
you may feel a need that i should have
been somewhere else right uh so that is
a carry a quick sentence and you get
fixated to the one or let's say for
instance if it joins the armed forces at
least to the time that you have signed
up for you got to be there so that's a
carry a quick send so that's something
that is uh also a reason for the carrier
pitfalls that you have because you're
not doing well and you can't come out of
it because of that carry out fixing
you're talking off
complacency
yeah so we just start taking things for
granted okay everything is going good so
nothing is going to happen to me and
that's a very serious problem and that
that's actually the one which surprised
a lot of people as to why suddenly
things became difficult for them
job hopping
now this is for in the survey uh in the
poll that we did people who are 10 years
and above will would understand this
much better
that anybody who job hops let's say in
10 years if you have job hopped six
times that means there is a
there is an
area of concern why do you have to leave
jobs six times
is it because you're not able to cope up
with the pressures is it because you're
not able to cope up with the challenges
of the job these are the questions that
comes to a mind of somebody
and and if you if you have lesser job
and you're not picking up another job
because of this reason then it is a
serious
serious carrier pitfall right so avoid
it roughly
two to three years max is something that
you have to
do this kind of uh you know it's it's
okay for you to be there but anything
less than that unless you're very strong
reasons you should try and avoid job
hopping
over confidence or being self-absorbed
because of you know we may be coming
from a very good institute we did a
graduation in mba from top institutes
and we feel that we are now cats
whiskers i mean nobody can touch us
and that kind of a confidence leads to
an arrogance it reflects on a behavior
it reflects on your attitude and this
can lead to a carrier pitfall so these
are the reasons that we saw and the
tenth one is
avoiding the writing on the wall
you have issues performance you will not
want to agree to it right you may have
got warnings you may have got
indications of it but you just ignored
it right and when it came to layoff you
were among the ones that got picked up
further so this is
the 10th reason for carrying pitfalls
there's so many other reasons but these
are the top ones which people have
given in the survey okay
right
then comes the top carrier pivots that
you have to do and what were the reasons
for that
the first one is you found the job no
longer exciting maximum of
the survey mentioned this as a reason
for the carrier pivot you didn't find
the job because for whatever reasons it
could be you picked at the wrong job it
could be because somebody or some other
compulsion is beyond your control or it
could be surely that i mean it didn't
excite you anymore you want to change
some people constantly seek change so
you may be part of that so whatever be
the reasons but this is a top reason for
a carrier pivot
then comes the inadequate inadequate
compensation you're not happy with what
they pay you you just took the job
because you wanted the job you had to
pay your bills you got do your emis you
picked it up but
that inner frustration was simmering
inside okay so these were the reasons
why you felt that you need to shift your
job
lack of carrier growth within the
company
now this is legitimate if there is no
growth obviously you would like to go on
and work somewhere there is growth and
companies for some for some reasons
because of the structure that they are
the metrics that they are in the
organization structure they may not be
able to give you an opportunity there so
that this is a reason for you to pivot
out from say a large company to a
startup because you get a low lex let's
say if i've been a hr
uh generalist in a large company paid
very handsomely but i realized that if i
need to move to a
leadership role like a head of hr then i
need to go to a medium or a small
industry or i need to go to a startup
for instance so that's reasons for your
carat pivots
and then lack of carrier growth within
the industry we've seen in the pandemic
that
there is the the uh the insurance the
banking they all did extremely well but
the travel the hotel industry
they actually bought it it was very
difficult for them to survive so that
clearly indicated there is uh there is a
gap there so people were doing jobs that
is
somebody in the hotel industry picked up
a job that has got nothing to do with uh
what they were doing so far so that was
the reasons for that carrier pivots that
happened
and armed forces here for instance you
know people who have done that 10 years
20 years 14 years and all that and
they're going to go to another still got
life left in them that's one of the
reasons a legitimate reason for a
carrier pivot
opportunities abroad okay that that's
something which
comes up the pandemic put some breaks on
this but still a lot of people moved
overseas to
get themselves upskilled to the better
universities there and from there to the
jobs that they could pick up from and
then you had the opportunities of the
home country because the fandom a lot of
people wanted to get back to their roots
get back home we've seen a lot of for
instance a lot of movement from the uae
to back to india right a lot of people
who worked there for
very many years they moved back because
opportunities at home country was there
and in fact there was less opportunities
there and therefore they had to move so
that was also a reason
now this is the most serious one wrong
career choice by virtue of a compulsion
which came from perhaps our parents from
the society that we are the culture that
we went from and we chose to carry it
and we realized that halfway through the
gallery some people who have gone into
iits i believe 27 of them
in uh
in the iits put together in one
particular year dropped out because they
didn't want
they realized that that's not where they
want to be and it's a dream to be in iit
by many of the students they aspire for
it so this is clearly a wrong career
choice okay and some have
had to pay for this
after about three years or five years or
maybe even between five to ten years
they realize that they're around they
are in the wrong carrier now look at the
amount of money that has been spent the
time that you spend because if you
change your carrier at that stage
you have to restart you will have to
your baseline is
far below so you're competing with
somebody who is far younger to you in
the carrier growth right it's okay about
age but i'm talking about career growth
so there it's it's the repercussions are
very very heavy
so handling or common carrier pitfalls
some of the ways that people
they themselves choose to say is that
avoid taking care for granted and that's
really right
uh let's not get the complacency mode
set and let's not take things for
granted oh i mean in this country i i've
been in this company
but i know people there
i'm
i have been doing extremely well in my
career so therefore in my studies so
therefore i should be doing well you
know you're taking things for granted
and you did not upskill
okay so you might be okay with your
graduation and all for a few years then
because the technology changes because
the new competitors have come the
companies have to move unless you keep
pace with that change you become
redundant right so upskilling you have
to keep pace with the latest right we've
seen in india the government offices
were always using files and over a
period of time they they don't even know
what uh they've not even seen computer
some of these employees but today
they're all working on computers they're
all networking and so that's how the
upskilling how important it is
having carrier goals
now
just imagine if you're playing football
when you play football just imagine
somebody picked up the goal post and
threw it away
i mean how will you play because unless
you have a goal in mind you can't play
the game
so you need to have your short term
which is about say two to three years in
your carrier goals a midterm which could
be anywhere between five to ten and long
term beyond that some people even say
long term is anything beyond five and
these are scales which are no hard and
fast rules but this is something that
you must have in your mind and this will
keep changing be very dynamic about it
right so you must have these goals so
that you can remain focused it helps you
to stay focused right and you don't
start taking things for granted
and this also helps in you know you must
be aware of complicity setting in and
when you have your goals and all of that
in place then you are conscious about it
avoid designation skill this you know
sometimes we say that the parents tell
us okay it'd be great if you become a
manager of a nightly company so once you
become a manager you feel that you
achieved the end okay so there's also
saying that you've
you have arrived at your level of
incompetence you can't go beyond that
now
don't get fixated because of that
because
you will get a lot of opportunities to
upskill and the world is changing and
unless you understand that you need to
change along with the world it's going
to be very difficult if you
if you do
get stuck stagnated in one place right
and you are likely to face a carrier
pitfall because of that
resolve vertical and horizontal we are
working with people right machines is
fine okay
maintenance can take care of missions
but when we work with human beings
right there are bound to be conflicts
which is likely to come up we must know
how to handle conflicts when i say
vertical conflicts it means
of the hierarchy and also people who are
working for you that's what vertical and
horizontal conflicts are ones with your
stakeholders could be your peers your
colleagues and somebody from
the department the neighboring
department and somebody working with the
operations working with the finance so
that's horizontal so this is something
that
new to resolve and these can lead to
carrier pitfalls if you're not able to
resolve in time sometimes the hard
option you may have to take if
everything else failed you certainly
have to take in a hard option that's
fine but that should not be the norm
behavioral corrections
this is something which
comes to that part of knowledge skill
attitude the attitude portion of it
more often than not we may not realize
how our behavior is
affecting others how is it hurting
people right in our
ambition to do well in the
desire to
meet the targets meet the objectives we
may not realize how we come across as
being extremely insensitive
right so that is something which if you
get a feedback and uh
people notice it right and if there is a
reason for choosing between two people
the one who is better
i wouldn't say behaved but one who's
been able to handle the emotions better
the eq is better they're the ones who
will get that
deal so be conscious of this if you get
any inputs make a conscious effort to
correct it all of us are human beings we
have aberrations so we must be
conscious of that and do something to
correct that
now we will talk about
the tools and the resources to handle
the carrier pitfalls there are umpteen
number of new go to the
internet you will get a lot of them
but what i've attempted to do in this
webinar is to
make sure that i give you something very
very simple something which all of us
can do we
i believe in my 34 years of career that
if you keep your things simple
the solutions simple right it may have
complex
workings which is fine but if you have
your broad
way of working if you keep that simple
you are tend to be more successful
so the tools that i'm going to share are
very common most of you know about it in
case if you don't know i will just touch
upon it right so the first tool that
will come to you is your carrier swot
analysis your strength weakness
opportunities and threats right i will
i will go very i'll take an example a
very simple example of how to do this
right
and this is important it helps us focus
on what otherwise we are in a muddle
there's so many thoughts keep coming so
we need to get focus on that
then there is something even more
simpler the t-chart analysis most of you
know this i will also show you an
example how it's being done right
because we have a lot of younger crowd
with us so for them it it would be a
learning right and then of course where
we are totally confused we're not sure
where we are we will be we'll be
wondering what is it that is then we
need to take help we need to be
scientific about it we have to use a
psychometric test the only
the fallout about psychometric test is
that you have to be really honest if you
really want
the test to be you're the the way that
you answer the questions you have to be
genuine about it otherwise the answers
to psychometric test can be skewed and
you will take a wrong decision based on
that
results and psychometric test has to be
done by somebody who's competent you
can't just download a psychometric test
from the internet and edit it and and
predict how you could go to a
go to an expert somebody who's qualified
let them do the test in case you feel
that you need to understand
what is the area that you need to
refocus re-carrier yourself
carrier counselors yes once suppose you
know that what are the options right you
may not be able to figure that out a
carrier counselor definitely is a person
who can give you the options and then
that helps you
make your decision
and then the lastly is a career coach
today i believe and the world has picked
us up very much especially in the
pandemic the coaching is the profession
to be
most or rather all of i would say i am i
can i can take the liberty of saying
that
most successful people
right from your jeff bezos to
bill gates and everybody they all have
coaches
is it because they're incompetent is it
because they don't know what to do it's
not that the coach is the one who is an
independent
and
a person whom you can use as a sounding
board for your what you want to take
forward what the future is thinking or
what what you're going through in life
you may not want to discuss with your
spouse you may not want to discuss with
your boss but a coach is a person who is
confidential whom you can trust and you
can take and that is and this is a very
positive way of going across i'm a coach
and i've realized
in the past one and a half years how
people have benefited because of
coaching and i don't give solutions
people take the decisions but a coach
helps you to take the decision so make
use of this fifth one when you are
addressing a carrier pitfall make use of
a carrier coach it's worth every time
that you pay the carrier coach
okay so we will take a look at what is
this carrier swot analysis just for
those those whose who are uninitiated
s transfer strength w for weakness and
threats and the opportunity so what we
do is that we list out what are the
strengths that we have picked up in this
just before we are going to
get into a carrier analysis right
we pick up our strength we list them out
then we take a look at a very very hard
look at our weaknesses all of us have
weaknesses let's not uh
you know
cheat ourselves we all have weaknesses
sometimes we might get to know what our
weaknesses from the others be open about
it
take positive criticism list out your
weaknesses which is preventing you from
walking towards that carrier pitfall
then what are the threats the threats
more often than not are external threats
you know the industry problem the
company going through a tough phase
these are the threats that is perhaps
taking you towards the carrier pitfall
fine and then based on this weakness and
threats we list out what are the
opportunities that we have to come out
of it right so what are the steps that
we need what are the action plans that
we need to do right so that is a process
that we need to follow this okay
now
i will give you a typical example i've
made it very simple okay so don't
don't go by why is it so simple i'm just
very simple so that a lot of us can
understand i just glanced at one of the
questions somebody asked but so let's
take a quick example right a typical
example so let's take like i told you
let's let's start what are strengths
right so we found that you know we are
good at communication skills and we have
a domain experience you know if you're
good at accounts or if you're good at
dealing with people you're good at
analytics that is something which is
good and you're supportive team you have
a good supportive team
that's definitely a strength that you
have in the current company that you're
working a stable work-life balance you
have it and you have a reputation in the
company these are the strengths that you
have
just some of just as an example for you
to list
let's take five of that now let's go see
what could be the possible weaknesses
that we have in this example
lack of analytical skills we're not very
good at maths we've ignored or we get
somebody else to do it you know we want
to stay within our comfort zone you know
like go to office come back do the work
go back that's it nothing well nothing
in
anything we don't want to raise our own
bar
and then we depend on the team for any
technical help because we don't want to
learn the technology
you know we are being stagnating so
these are the weaknesses that you've
realized okay
then let's see what are the threats
we knew that in our past few appreciates
that we've dropped a performance by 50
time
and we have not we are in the 50
percentile in the team that we are
working right we have not worked in the
areas of improvement
people told us
boss told us but we just ignored it
and then change of management there is
acquisitions happening companies get
bought by something merger and
acquisitions happen a bigger fish eats a
smaller fish and they have a better say
than the smaller one so a lot of people
churn out during this particular time so
this is a serious uh
you know carrier pitfall that you will
be addressing but if you realize that
what is your stakes in that well in time
then you can take your steps for that
and then of course this is mba we may
have done our mba 10 15 years back
right but that's not relevant anymore
because the world has changed extremely
fast we have moved in terms of
technology fast in the way that the
companies have
evolved themselves over the time the way
the competition has come up way that the
world is moving forwards because of the
threats environmental threats all of
this
makes you rethink because we got used to
the way that we have been taking
decisions the management wants us to
change that thought
they want us because they believed in us
we've been loyal to them and so
therefore we have some of our assets
some good things but if we scale up
scale now and that is where we need to
do an mba maybe 10 years 15 years no or
officers who are transiting this is the
time for them to
do an mba because they're going into
corporate entirely a different
environment
there is a need for doing an mba and how
do we do that is that emba which is the
executive mba because this is what and
today
when i did a lot of snip was checking
about what is more available in the
market
the executive mba is the the in thing it
is trending very very strongly today
thanks to the pandemic thanks to the
requirement of upscaling the requirement
it is happening
now we have listed out the weakness we
have listed out the threats now let's
see what are the opportunities how do
you create opportunities out of this
weakness and the threats okay so let's
take this
upskilling
the online course let me see if i can
get this no okay
yeah
error option
it's no it's not coming up okay
the upskilling of online course on
analytics and the latest software now
this is the weakness that you had you
know your analytics skills you were you
lacked them and you were depending on
technical help so if you are skill on
the online course for analytics and the
latest software you should be able to
take care of these two
staying in the comfort zone is something
that you have to work on yourself okay
so that is
something that you do it yourself
and then you see your your performance
is 55 most companies although some of
the companies have got away with it they
still use bell curve for performance for
the compensation so if you are part of
the bottom 50 bottom 10 20 percent you
are certainly a threat as far as your
job is concerned so you got to move out
of that for that you have to be creative
you have to show that you have some
initiatives you did something different
when you created the project whatever
work that you're working
and that's how you do it and this change
man especially when there is a change of
management you have because the new
management do not know what you have
done you should have actually
recorded your metrics you could have
documented your metrics so that's very
important and that is why uh the
the last one you know your performance
metrics that i was talking of that is
where it's very important whatever you
have achieved in terms of percentage in
terms of number of hours maybe or in
terms of
monitoring terms of how much money you
saved or how much revenue you earned all
of that if you could document over a
period of time in your own way and make
it
useful during performance appraisals
that is going to
stay in good state for you
right and lastly if you're about 10 15
and you feel that you need up so please
do an emba it's very important and the
companies
there is very strong
evidence of companies having paid 20 30
40 percent more because you have
upskilled yourself because of an emba
now it depends from company to company
industry to industry and of course in
what position you are okay
see suit if you're going to go there you
definitely have to be an mba right
okay so
then comes this teacher this is very
simple quite easy quite easily done just
divide your complete issues into pros
and cons so you have mentioned your pros
out here the work-life balance timely
promotions incentives your growth from a
graduate engineer trainee to the manager
your domain experience supportive team
i.t park and the hybrid working
right these are the pros that you have
currently before your when you visualize
your pitfall and the cons are like same
examples that i gave you in the swot
analysis lack of analytic skills work is
not challenging anymore and these were
the reasons that
what happens one second sorry
okay let the carrot to the back sorry
sorry about that oh fine so stagnated
performance lack of mba
for senior promotions pandemic related
job insecurity companies at loss okay
and the commute distance is too far away
conflict with the immediate boss and the
spouse relocation has happened these are
the cons now how do you deal with this
right so little pull the cat out of the
bag again
right so
any issues that you have and that's why
i put the heading like handling personal
and professional life situation they're
all same
right any issues that you have there are
two aspects to it
you can break it down to two aspects
simple as simple as that right now a lot
of
people who are fond of complicated ways
of looking at things will go this is i
mean how can you be how can you talk
something like this
believe me some of the solutions in
world and the life is very simple all
you need to look for it and apply
yourself
the first and foremost is that in all
your situations there are things that
are controllable
that you can control perhaps you have
not attempted it but there are things
that are controllable and then there are
things that is beyond your control you
can't do anything about it it just hit
you
pandemic for instance right it's not
you're doing
right so if it is hit you so this is not
controllable a combination of this is
what your current situation is right so
in the previous example where i've
talked about the t scale fine
in this what we do the pros we know and
in the cons what we have done is that
i've shown you in red what i've shown
you in red is the uncontrollable god
with something that you can't control i
won't say uncontrollable some things you
can't control pandemic related job in
security i mean this is not in your
hands really speaking companies and loss
for the past two years fine so if they
are looking at a layoff it's not your
doing your spouse's relocation because
it's important you need the
money and you need to plan your finances
there is an emi running there's mortgage
running so if that's the case then the
spouse has to relocate for
improving your finances now these are
all things that is beyond you so this is
not comfortable but what is in blue
they are all controllable
lack of engineering skills you can
upskill work challenging not anymore you
raise your bar go to a different
department maybe even change your job
make it more challenging that's up to
you depends on team for technical
assistance once you are depending so
heavily on them you can move out of that
and then you can do this and then
stagnated performance this is something
that is because of your own doing
sometimes the company may not have any
positions beyond what you're already
there
do you want to move out from there some
of the government jobs for instance you
have no scope till most of the time you
will be just having a very very minimal
amount of changes would you like to
accept that or is it uh
is it something that is acceptable to
you now those are questions that you
need to ask so they are actually
comfortable controllable with you
lack of mba for senior promotion so you
know that if you do an emba you can
handle this similarly commute distances
to area move closer to the place
relocate shift so these are solutions
that you have rather than commuting some
for maybe it's expensive is there some
other way of handling that these are
questions that is controllable conflict
with immediate voice i am putting this
under control
most of the time the conflict is on
assumed perception
you have assumed some certain perception
your boss has got certain perception
they didn't match
and that's why there's an expectation or
surely because of an attitude issues not
your own attitude the boss could be an
attitude which you can't put up with
it's fine
is there a way to work around it if you
can try that out either speaking to the
boss and if you have tried out with
speaking with colleagues taking help of
somebody else and all of that and if it
doesn't work out which in some cases it
will not then certainly move on right
but that's controllable right so this is
why i have said that these are the ways
that how you handle this
fine
okay so these are the 10 carrier best
practices from what we've discussed so
far
carrier decision should be yours please
don't go by opinions of others
especially people who are transiting
from the armed forces from the uniform
to the series please do your homework
ask pointed questions
have a robust financial plan aligned to
your carrier expectations and that's
very important
unhappiness at work can lead to
professional cancer if this is
psychosomatic if you are
stressed if you are
you know too uh you're not happy
basically it's actually playing up on
your body in the long run and that's why
i said it to psychosomatic so you have
to figure out what is that's making you
happy should you need to change the
location should you need to change the
uh the the ambience in which you are go
ahead and do it if that's making you
happy because that is the solution
career versus life
now this is a very it's partly the home
life uh work life balance that you're
talking about
you've got to draw very clear lines
between what is that you're going to
dedicate for your carrier and what is it
that is your life unless you dedicate
like if you want to be yourself you
there is a me time that you have to be
with you you can't get up in the morning
and be on the
mobile phone throughout till the time
you drop into your bed that means you're
being ruled by that device you have to
have it because if you have a me time if
you have a time for yourself you are
spending it on a hobby you are spending
it you are indirectly being more and
more productive
it affects positively on your work
that is why this have to be very clear
and you have to make known to your
people people in your workplace what is
it that you will not compromise be very
clear about it
okay and there are times when career
should take
over more than life you must understand
it and allow that much of priority for
it there are times when life takes more
over carrier understand it and make
yourself available for life for that for
instance somebody is seriously sick
right those kind of issues document your
work i already touched upon this
evaluate and then discuss carrier
aspirations with stakeholders this is
something which to be assumed that obas
knows what i'm doing
please you may have to remind your boss
through the reports that you send every
week maybe every month or every quarter
what you're doing progress it there
document it because when you do the
appraisal these things will come in
handy
networking today this is the world for
you
if you don't network you are nobody if
you don't brand yourself you're nobody
whether you're starting your carrier or
whether you're middle in mid and beyond
definitely network is the one that is
going to fetch you any opportunities it
is the one that's going to make you
successful networking
right so make use of networking linkedin
is a platform that you must make it your
spouse as far as your profession is
concerned it is that important
unprofessional that work i'm not going
to elaborate much of that you all know
this what it is
avoid it and lastly don't bring bridges
yes we may have our issues with people
but at least when you're leaving a
company please leave with a very good
note or at least be
leave make peace and leave the reason
i'm saying this is that the new company
does a background verification check
most companies do that and especially at
the senior level and therefore what
happens is that somebody reaches out to
your boss because you got to tell them
who your previous boss was and if you
have lied to them in the interview and
if they check up and he gives or she
gives a totally different story
your current job is at stake so let's
not burn bridges be careful leave in a
very good note make it your effort your
initiative to live in a good note
okay and finally seek a mentor and a
coach i have already touched upon this
this is very important for your career
practice have a coach have a mentor very
important
right so this is how you reach out to me
and uh
this is uh this is of course you can
take a screenshot this is my this is my
phone number i'm on telegram as well as
whatsapp my email id and my
website i have a website you can access
me through that and i'm on linkedin
please connect with me on linkedin and i
have my own youtube channel which has
got carrier enhancing
youtube recordings that is there and
please go and take a look at that so if
you're a shammer you don't want to note
all this right i have a qr code
uh you have most of you must be having a
smartphone take a
qr shot of this and this has got a
digital listing card of mine all that
you've
done is also available there
right
and now i go to the question answer
stuart i'll seek your help in helping me
go to the q a
sure we have a number of questions that
have come in and um
we have uh abhishek makes an interesting
observation sometimes our family
background creates our pitfalls
you comment on that a little
yeah so uh abhishek i just mentioned
that you know
can i expand this
oh okay this is different
okay
oh shall i uh yeah yeah okay
yeah okay
if you stop sharing then uh just one
second i'll do that
okay
so abhishek had that question right
so uh uh abhishek uh so your your
question was on uh if you have uh
the compulsions
the family compulsions for you to in a
career you have to take a call and you
make use of the swot analysis that we
discussed put that there and then if not
you can use the t uh you know the pros
and cons use that as a tool list it out
and when you do this do it by yourself
you can seek help from others to give
you inputs but you must do this
essentially yourself and find out for
yourself which is more important at that
particular moment
just remember one thing abhishek that
situations whether it's work or whether
it's life whatever it is they are all
temporary
and how temporary is something that we
can't really uh put our finger on but
they are temporary so therefore what is
it that is more important for you at
that moment to take a decision is it
leaning towards career is it leaning
towards a family compulsion that you
have that's a call only you can take it
maybe you can seek a help of a coach to
help you decide that but that's a way
out for you
i hope i've answered that
yeah i think that also addresses a
question from probably asked about
how you know the decision on your career
is your own decision and i think
as you described it
doing that
calculation on your own
yeah
helps you do that
we have several questions about job
hopping
and we have some people some people who
say that uh you know
what's too much for job hopping and then
the other question is
what about people who
stay with the company for five or ten
years and
are accused of being stuck
okay
uh is that the question
right
okay fine so let's take uh the first one
where job hoping what is
when do you say that you are job hopping
right um
a few years back let's put about 10 15
years back working in a company or uh
20 years back you know
looking for a
golden watch and all that was the thing
okay but in the last few uh perhaps a
decade a little more than a decade
uh
you change your job every maybe three to
five years
that's become the trend the millennials
are facing that the z
uh
generation are doing that they don't
stick around for more than two three
years and they go job and and the
reasons are also not just because they
want to hop the job it's because the
opportunities are that much more
and the industries also expanded that
much and uh
that that's a reason why this is
happening so if you were asked what is a
job happening anything less than three
years two years
three years if it is one or two it's
okay but in a ten year carrier if it is
if you have moved two or three times in
a ten-year carrier it's okay but if you
move more than five times
then seriously it's a cause of consent
definitely people would like to know why
you did it okay and the behavioral uh
for very
very intelligent as well as very matured
and uh qualified uh
what shall i say uh interviewer he will
be able to pick out through behavioral
event interviewing questions how far are
you
saying the truth about it
so be careful about that because you
must have very valid reasons more often
than not we've just given up
for a particular situation so that is
answers that particular question now
come to the second one where i mentioned
about stagnation right in your job where
you've been stagnating in a job
now
what happens is that over a period of 10
15 years if you're in a particular
company it's because that you have gone
from a ged to that particular position
that you are there okay is that the
question that you have to ask if you're
already being there is that
is it actually stagnation you may have
grown up within about two or three
positions within the company when you
came up to 10 years or 15 years that is
okay
now what you have to ask a question is
do i have
more growth within the same company that
now that i've been here for 10-15 years
that's a question that you have to ask
if there is still opportunities for you
there by upskilling by perhaps doing an
emba refresh
then of course you can still continue to
be there there's no harm and fast rule
that you should leave okay just because
you did 10 or 15 it's more of what is
your opportunity what is the comfort
level that you're looking at or do you
want to sign off after next through of
three or five years by staying back in
the company so that's a call that you
need to take
yeah that's what i have to say on that i
have a couple of questions about uh
gaps in in the resume or job gaps um
we have sacha who has had a
couple of gaps due a couple years out
due to covid
we have uh
jacob who's had some job gaps
um
regarding uh
a disability that's gotten him
fired
even though that's not legal
it still happened to him so how how do
you um
deal with that
okay as a pitfall
right so um in the past one and a half
years ever since okay so since 2000
uh when the kovitz started from 19 20 21
right we all understand everybody in the
industry
as long as they are human beings they
understand that people have gone through
kovit if not them at least their family
or somebody near and dear to them have
got affected for which they had to
suffer you know a period of absence or
whatever it is everybody understands
that
what
people are going to ask is that for
instance because of cobit i didn't i
lost my job and i've not been doing
anything say for one year i'm just
giving an example right
in that one year
what did i do to upskill myself did i
use it usefully or did i just sat home
and put on weight
did i
learn a new skill did i upgrade myself
in the existing domain that i'm already
good at
if i have done something like that then
it's not a minus
it's not a disadvantage then people
understand yes you lost a job you didn't
get another one and that's why it is
earlier before the corbid any gap beyond
six months used to be a question that
they would ask the interviewers to why
are you
why is the gap of six months and more
okay but in this last two three years
that's really not a area of concern
unless you have valid reasons covent is
a valid reason not talking about
disability it is a health hazard that
you went through right it's something
like maternity which people are going
through you uh you have to be a mother
for a certain number of months that you
have maybe six months eight months or
whatever it is you may be off your work
maybe at best you can do a little bit of
work as work from home that's all it is
but we need to understand
if you have people who do not understand
this it's not worth working for them
clear very clear accept
don't work for them
leave
look for another job leave
anything else
jacob also asks
because he's
i believe he's enrolled in the simple
learn data analytics course
and he has a bachelor's in mechanical
engineering um with a couple of years
experience so
he's curious to know about that kind of
a pivot um
is it reasonable for him to expect to be
able to pivot from mechanical
engineering into data analytics and come
out with a
a good position
okay so uh jacob is the one who asked
this question am i right
yes
okay so jacob uh this is how it goes um
you know you spend a lot of effort and
time and everything to do mechanical
engineering for whatever reasons let's
not you're not discussing the reasons
because that's past right currently
there is a skill set with you based on
that the mechanical engineering and
uh and whatever that you've done so far
will need analytics today
uh more than yesterday today a lot of
decisions are being taken based on
analytics that's why when i tell people
who are moving out from carrier to a
different carrier when they're doing the
pivot analytics is something that you
must it's it's part of your life now any
decision today your boss is likely to
ask you why this decision
what's the reason to support it what are
your facts to support it they're
definitely going to ask because it's all
a metric driven that's good now there
may be certain decisions that has to be
intuitive okay which you cannot ignore
fine but that intuition has to be based
on some
some framework of a decision which is
based on metrics
so that's also a part of rule so when
when i'm talking like this what i'm
saying is that you cannot totally
diverse your mechanical engineering from
it that is the skill set that you
arrived but while you there are you need
to explore right what are the areas of
analytics that you need to specialize on
there are business analytics then there
are something uh called uh you know
scientific analysis which you have to go
there are something a software analytics
that you have to be proficient on there
are software that you need to specialize
on you have to answer the question where
do you want to go what are you
comfortable with what kind of job are
you looking for maybe you could discuss
that with a carrier counselor or maybe
you do a psychomatic test if you're not
sure where your strengths are and you're
not able to pinpoint there
do all of that make use of that and then
maybe even speak to a coach when you do
all of this you are actually using data
you're using information to make your
decision and as you get more and more
information believe me you get more and
more clarity in what you want to do
currently sitting and trying to figure
out what should i do puts you more and
more into that confused state
right and that happens to everybody even
the most intelligent has to go through
that so therefore it is nothing to do
with how smart you are it is more to do
how practical are you
right so they got all the best on that
choose what is uh what suits you and i'm
sure you will be able to have a
combination skill and it also widens
your employability too remember take it
from that point of view and picture
interview conversations that way as to
why you did this to enhance an existing
scheme
it's also important to remember that
analytics is an applied field and it
requires domain knowledge so
if you've got a background in mechanical
engineering
and you've got a lot of domain knowledge
that you can apply in many industries
with respect to
mechanical
aspects and understanding how to use
analytics there so
that's a a
leg up on the on the competition
kelly has a
kelly has a quick question for you prem
uh she missed the statistics you
mentioned
about uh the benefits of hybrid working
and the increase in productivity that it
yields
okay i'll just repeat it for you so this
was a study done in october or number
i'm not very sure and it was in 2001 and
according to them uh
i think this was
yeah this was done by ddi consultants
correct yeah ddi consultants had done
this these are global consultants so
they said
that
uh
on an average
26 hours was the additional productivity
that
an employee put because of the hybrid
working
that was a statistic that i shared
we had
several
questions regarding the emba
um
a couple of them have to do with uh age
and whether there's a higher limit
on the age of somebody before taking in
the mba
after which it would not be productive
and the other question is whether you
prefer online or offline do you see a
difference
okay great question indeed wonderful
now um in the emba the uh
who asked this question and i won't know
which country is it from
uh so most of the the questions were
asked by several people one of them
they were all india i think susan and uh
tahir and
um
that's okay
it's not important right
most of the uh most of the countries
okay
uh emba like it's like executive mba the
basic qualification requirement is
the number of experience that you put in
right
for instance the uh they would say that
it could be five years or it could be
ten years or even the senior courses
emba that you do which they call it as
the senior
transformational leadership and they
have so many names that they have right
i'm not picking up institutes by name
deliberately because i'm not
promoting them but
they have these as the minimum
qualifications and you should have a
basic degree that's all they need and
they also say that your basic degree
should be about 50 percent you should
have got your pass marks this is
essentially what is everywhere
and in case if you have not got this 50
percent at least a certain number of
increased years you may have let's say
if they say it was only two years of
experience if you don't have 50 marks
they would say five years of experience
so that is all the qr that they are
asking for right and then they what they
go through and this is where the tough
part is what they go through is they go
through an interview and they ask you to
give you a statement of purpose or maybe
they ask you to write an essay as to why
do you want to do the emba they want to
know your purpose what is it just to do
and get a qualification is it to enhance
your career is it to enhance what you
already learned so those things come out
in the interview before they select you
so that is currently what the status is
bmb is now the
question of the age
they're not worried about age
i have never come across because i did a
lot of uh
a lot of people approached me for career
uh
coaching and when i have spoken to a
number of top institutes nowhere is
there an upper limit
so that's not a criteria at all an upper
limit right as long as you're able to
tell them why you want maybe at 60 or 70
why do you need if you are say for
instance you may be having a family
business right i'm just giving example
and you want to continue want to do
better because youngsters are coming
there and then you are not able to
correlate with them so you want to do an
emba and you have the desire to study
and you did that so that's okay they're
they're more concerned about why you
want to do it if you're able to convince
them that age is certainly not a factor
so
we have
some people who ask about
making a pivot and
how to position yourself if you don't
have relevant experience in the new area
um how do you position your skills as
transferable
wonderful
okay
so this is let's say i will take i'll
give an example with the
veterans for instance the armed forces
veterans right
they've come in an environment where
their leadership skills are the highest
right because i mean every the moment
they step into the uh academy to the
time that they leave
leadership is certainly they've got they
have they do a lot of things fine now
they want to come to the corporate now
that's a pivot for them right now they
do not know what happens in the
corporate how is the business there how
is life there so they need to understand
that so they have to undergo courses
like this emba for instance or
institutes who specialize in uh you know
grooming the veterans to move there i
just talked about veterans now so they
have a case for doing the pivot there so
they can do that and now what happens is
that the the
the
the thing that you need to be very
conscious there is that
whether you're a veteran or whether you
are you have
you know done up a particular carrier
and you want to pivot and go to entirely
a different carrier
what you must understand is if i upskill
myself whatever i'm upskilling
how am i going to use that knowledge in
the
new environment that you're going to
work
obviously you've not been there but how
are you going to apply it how can you
apply whatever that you have upskilled
now how can you apply it from the
current work that you are however able
to relate because when you go for that
interview
what they're trying to find they know
that you are not there you have not been
there but they know that you have
upskilled yourself to be there so
they're trying to find out from you
how good are you at
creating that adaptability because
adaptability is intelligence of the
highest order how are you intelligently
able to use that knowledge to that
environment that are coming they're
asking that and they will ask you to
relate it with that existing
uh domain that you already worked for
are you able to apply it how did you
apply it if you're able to convince them
that they know that once you come across
on this side of the field you will
certainly apply that thought process and
you will be able to enhance yourself and
work out so this is more of how you are
applying so when you do don't do
certifications for the sake of
certifications don't do a emba just
because it will help you get
x number of
thousands of dollars because you do that
that's not the point the point is how
are you going to enhance your
operatability how are you going to
enhance your job applicability if you're
able to convince there then you are
definitely there
yes
thank you um
so
i had a question here
about gig workers and contract workers
and do you have advice for them
yes
so um
it's like i said that you know for by
the association of chambers of commerce
have done a study and they have said
that in 2024
uh 17 percent increase and that's
455 million billion dollars u.s dollars
right and secondly they also went to
predict that in 2027 in usa
the number of gig workers is
going to be more than the non-gig
workers
that's how important gig workers and
contract workers
now let me uh
i will speak about the contract workers
because
contract is
a document that is telling you that for
a particular period of time you're going
to work and that's
that's appears to be a big disadvantage
when you work under contract
but what is not also uh people don't
look at is that the contract can be
renewed and for that you have to remain
upscaled
okay so you know the question that we
had where somebody said a lot of people
said that one of the reasons of carrier
pitfalls is that stability of job right
so when you're on contract workers you
know that your contract is for two years
three years and you need to renege
especially people are working in say the
marine engineering you know those they
have all contracts six months contracts
expense off into then again they go on
to contract so some countries contract
is the way of working in the other
countries contract is to beat a system
so that they go they can cut out the red
tapism so it is more of the way that you
employ resources employ a head count
that is where the contract is okay some
people feel that you know by employing
myself as a contract i might lose some
privileges or i might lose so when you
discuss your contract with the people or
when you sign up for a contract you got
to make sure what are the things that
you're getting in comparison with the
people who are permanently employed
fine but what i see is that more and
more of the
uh the functional jobs are getting more
into a contract growth
it's very very rare that you find middle
and the senior levels going on a
contract okay so there it is a different
uh
there you have compensation giving you
more of your stability as far as the job
is concerned right they might give you
you know the esops okay
you buy the stock of the company so that
gives you a lot of alignment for the
loyalty so that's where that goes
um
we don't have time for
uh more than this one last question
unfortunately and i want to apologize to
everybody because we have so many
questions in but
has given you
his contact information and
so i would urge you to
reach out to him but here's this last
question
from rahul and i think this would be a
great way to illustrate
coaching
he says hi pram can you please guide me
with the relocation issue so i'm getting
good calls i have upgraded myself
where i've been seeing myself getting
good offers but i'm unable to relocate
to tier one cities because my partner's
a government employee and her relocation
opportunities aren't as good as mine or
as smooth as mine rather
also they have a three-year-old child
and they all want to be under the same
roof so
relocating without his partner and child
is
not a
good choice so what can you
offer rahul on that
okay rahul i don't want to be in your
situation firstly
okay so uh see rahul you've got to take
a call on this see
okay let me i'll give you my own example
fine i'm married uh to a left-hand
colonel from the army so we
were married for about more than 20
years in the armed forces so she is
deployed somewhere so my son grew up
partly with her spotless with my with my
parents so that's we got to figure out a
workaround for it
fine if both the carriers are important
if both the carriers are important you
have to figure out a workaround you got
somebody to be there
so let's say you have to move to a
relocated place and if it's imperative
that you go there whereas your partner
stays back wherever he or she is you've
got to figure out a way that how can you
be
unless if it is you know two different
countries then that's the people have
are even doing that there are a lot of
people who've gone to uae and who are
from indian cities and they come back
only once in a year for about two or
three months when they're allowed to
come uh is that acceptable to you do you
want to accept that and go and take the
job is the question that not just you
your partner your spouse both of you
have to sit together it's a joint
decision
okay so that is something which is
important and you have to use the t
scale for this
this is not a swot analysis one this is
more of a t scale one what are the pros
what are the cons of you relocating not
really cricketing take out score out
what is
not controllable and then what can you
control how can you manage can you put a
uh can somebody work with this be at
home can you come once in a while how
frequently can you tie up with your
current employer so that they can allow
you to travel for a certain time can you
operate on a hybrid model
you know can you work for some time in
in part of a month here and then go back
and be in the
new location these are things that you
can negotiate you know because certain
part of your work you can do it from
work from home so this is how you got to
go about it use your use your influence
and if there is anything that is not
working uh for you you got to give your
company a way as to how you can work
around that situation it should be
win-win for both
if it is a win-win for both i'm sure
there should be a workaround for it
great
well thank you for for that uh tram i'm
going to go ahead and
present the last part of the
webinar to close out
but i wanted to give
you an opportunity to thank everyone
and for
i i wanted you also to get a chance to
reiterate your
um
reach outs
yeah so
all of these are available i will see
for a second here if i can put them
into the chat so that would be wonderful
if you can put them into the chat and if
they can take a screenshot of this you
can reach out to me i do help a lot of
people in their career transition
people who are pivoting in their carrier
what are the options how do they
consider the options how do they
uh
how to explore it and how do you base it
on facts how do you base it on on clear
clear metrics that's what i insist on
that's why i help people on and a lot of
officers who are transiting from the
uniform to the series i do help a lot of
them please reach out to me on this one
i can be irrespective of whichever part
of the world you are you can reach out
to me on my uh website or on my phone or
even on my email premium.com
please reach out to me and we can surely
work around how to you know get the
light at the end of the tunnel certainly
we can i must thank you thanks simply
learn thanks stuart for helping us do
this flawlessly and uh we've been able
to uh you know i tried to keep this
within 50 minutes i hope i've done that
but since we had a lot of questions and
i'm sure you can always shoot those
questions which we didn't answer you can
always shoot that to us to me in this
and also stuart can help do that thank
you so much once again and have a
splendid carry i hope that five percent
who are not too good now i hope they are
not there they are in the top right
okay
thank you and um
i just want to um as we're finishing up
i want to reiterate that we have a
free program for upskilling
this is
the introductory level of our some of
our paid programs so these are
self-directed learning and
allow you to
learn from video content in many
different skills and
then you earn
certificates for these
particular courses and if you want to
move forward then you are able to
look at our other
more in-depth courses
so i'm going to put this into the chat
as well
to let you
have the link
and
finally i'm going to mention that we by
the way i do want to reassure you that
we will be sending out a link to the
recording of this session
along with a link to the pdf of the
presentation slides
in an email that you'll receive tomorrow
and
finally i want to mention that we have
another webinar coming up next week in
the digital marketing domain so if
you're in that domain or interested in
it
or if you have friends who are
please let them know about
this
session with
uh matt bailey of sitelogic marketing
debunking seo myths seo search engine
optimization and
he'll give you
advice and information about how to
avoid being distracted by
wrong information in that area and focus
on how to do it right so
that's next
wednesday same time
and
in the meanwhile you can connect with us
through our social media handles
at simply learn on facebook and twitter
or simply learn on
linkedin
we look forward to seeing you at future
webinars and we certainly look forward
to having you join the simply learn
learning community and with that
i'll conclude
our webinar thank you so much
you